ten words well that's ages what if I get
bored I needed television a couple of
books anyone for chess bring me knitting
[Music]
so we're gonna do something a little
different this time this was an idea
that was suggested by one of my
commenters named Jordan he asked if I
will be up for trying to do ten word
reviews for the entirety of Doctor Who
or not all that new whoo because I'm
still catching up on classic whoo and I
saw it I kind of laughed at it then I
thought about it and I was drinking I'm
like I'm gonna take that challenge so a
couple of things to keep in mind about
this first of all these are not
necessarily reflective of my actual
thoughts about the episode this is
really contending it down sometimes it's
for a joke sometimes I'm gonna make fun
of episodes I actually really like so
you know don't take these as my ruse I'm
also not sticking number scores on to
these this is just for fun
also apologies to jello apocalypse cuz I
know that that channel has done
something similar with Disney movies
although they did do actual kind of
reviews and like give them scores and
rankings and I'm not doing that that
having been said let's do this need an
ordinary girl also this alien I guess
there goes three-quarters of our annual
effects budget I wonder if it's really
ghosts
oh wait it's aliens politicians are
bloating gas bags get it
if by world's war you mean conflict in
one building how to make a trash can
with a plunger threatening also the slow
dull and kind of pointless game what if
the Lango leaders had more daddy issues
meet your new nightmare fuel dancing is
sex or were we too subtle for you can we
redeem the farting aliens not quite good
try these show parodies won't date this
episode at all deus ex machina
resolution mark 1
here's rose whining also that alien has
a new body did the nurses cough up hair
balls into bedpans Wow a werewolf on
Doctor Who up wait it's aliens blatant
fanservice that actually works stop
punching me in the fields Moffat winner
of the title that makes the build-up
pointless award the generic robot
version of Cybermen was always scariest
right feed me a better script because
this isn't working this is so awesomely
mysterious what's causing it all oh it
was the devil that's cool I guess now
with less doctor and more fellatio jokes
for kids more like fear the confused
tone and weird execution am i right
Earth's invaded by the least interesting
version of Cybermen hrodna I have
something in my eye just need a bit of
this is better than that Julia Roberts
movie meet the new companion who will be
criminally underutilized later Harry
Potter saves the day even in other
fictional worlds Oh interspecies couples
are adorable just don't think about it
check out all these genuine New York
exid's an interesting change to the
nature of never mind it's dead when
creature design ambition far exceeds the
CGI budget we don't need more than a
real time gimmick right remove the
doctors uniqueness and get a great story
neat I've got a bit of a temper there
don't you doc he said the wiggly wobbly
thing how to make longtime fans squee
with one twist you will forever hate to
the song voodoo child after the
deus ex machina resolution mark too
cartoonish bill and undermines oddly
sincere character drama and tragedy
here's your sketch comedy bit now let
the woman work full payoff is on a
seven-year delay we're not gonna address
that guy totally changing species
how many short jokes can we cram in the
day is saved by the Weasly secondary
villain wins the biggest plot thread
that will never resolve award
nothing says 1920s like a giant wasp
wait what are you afraid of the dark
just got pwned there's that seven-year
emotional payoff delay again you'll
never play an imitating game with your
kids again have we really not done the
butterfly effect thing before the
all-star companions round up our two of
the same doctor and thus fanfiction.net
exploded winner of the biggest lie
serving as episode title award plenty of
the lazy alien designs flies and
stingrays edition the doctor was overdue
to be a total jackass wolf saves
Christmas or the Christmas special at
least epic casting for Rassilon prepare
for disappointment on the rematch best
episode to use a pun as the title so the
Beast doesn't eat kids
you're still kidnapping children
runner-up for the biggest plot thread
that will never resolve you will come to
fear the name angel Bob huh so that
would have resolved itself without the
doctor I wonder if it's really vampires
outweigh its aliens alternate realities
with evil Willy Wonka as the tour guide
time for one of the better creature
design updates also known as the
Silurians can never catch a break
I'm not crying you're crying
what if doctor who was a home life
sitcom it's a trap deus ex machina
resolution mark 3 singing makes fish fly
top that dickens spoilers it's the most
obvious possible person in that suit
here you come the man in black
I won't let you remember is it really a
siren out not wait it's aliens excerpt
from the dr. secret erotic dream diary
there goes fanfiction.net again your
dad's dead but here's his sticky clone
okay I honestly didn't see that one
coming
or you know just lock Hitler in a
cupboard parenting is hard the
ham-fisted metaphor edition she made a
sonic screwdriver
you can't gloss over that your fears
will kill you made truly literal love
conquers all even cybernetic conversion
let's tie up one of rivers loose ends
never mind
the Narnia have the answer did we screw
up a better version of Clara mark-1 well
the title like this our work is now done
tossing a bone to the cyberpunk fans oh
just run down the clock to the anti
climactic ending just don't think about
the Statue of Liberty thing better
version of Clara mark - now with the
Eddie references killer Wi-Fi I think
you overreached with that one there's a
speech about memory and yeah I forget
the rest time for one of our less good
creature design updates a haunted house
I wonder outright it's aliens again duh
I have harmony call back now clap you
sheep we needed an excuse to bring the
Paternoster gang back this really needed
to be a two-parter without the kids is
it Larry tell me it's Larry I've got a
bet I don't care that it's a short it's
awesome hope you didn't come here to see
the time war the time of the doctor
hanging around waiting to die a dinosaur
in London how will they it's dead we
wish Dalek Caan was still around let's
rebuild him that time that banter saved
the entire episode good monologue now
shut up and let it be scary
sadly closed at oceans twelve than
ocean's 11 everybody wanted the doctor
to get a day job right the moons an egg
that lazy
how's our title this goofy make an
episode this good but you won't look at
graffiti the same again
poetic narrative fail the identity of
Missy is the second most obvious answer
scary new way to cyber cover out they
blew up we all wanted Santa in the Alien
franchise right best cold-open ever
here's some heartfelt bonding between
enemies
you ain't never mind oh my god it's goes
oh wait it's aliens again what an
awesome creature design shame II can
barely move Viking gods and wait for it
yup it's aliens so apparently there are
Thundercats in the universe hi lion-o
how to under deliver on a great metaphor
that scale model of war speech though
corner of your eye gunk sure is spooky
right now a beautifully portrayed death
with great impact a beautifully
portrayed battling of grief with
triumphant resolution how to ruin two
previous great episodes in 60 minutes
how to bring a goofy romp to a heartfelt
conclusion since there's no good recent
Superman movies we made this sentient
fuel okay so I didn't see that coming
not as scary as the emoji movie Kevin
love's them from the past is bad haunted
house again and oh it's alien bugs this
time capitalism from the future is bad
what really happens if we realized were
in the matrix so the pyramid were built
by aliens no love conquers old again
colonialism sure was messed up huh what
really happened to the Lost Legion
outright aliens oh right creeping
dehumanized Cybermen were the scary ones
duh deus ex machina resolution mark 4
applies only to companion the doctor
gets to be his own backwards thinking
sidekick so there you go guys this was
this was fun actually this was this was
a fun challenge to figure out ways to do
that and
how the reception's of this video is I'd
be up for doing something like this
again I think the number of shows that I
could actually do it on is kind of
limited but I could do it for something
like Buffy cowboy bebop Farscape baby
you know there are options out there but
in any case did you have fun with this
do you think I just I just crapped all
over the entire concept whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all that
stuff you know the things the links the
subscribes the Twitter follows the
podcast lessons the patreon support
maybe just saying the options there
links for all this stuff is down below
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]